First Lady Joe Biden catching some
plaque on International women's day
girls everywhere need to know that there
are women fighting for them and winning
opening doors transforming schools and
communities and governments building a
better world for all of us oh so that
was the first lady presenting the women
of Courage award to 11 recipients from
around the world during a ceremony at
the White House
including a transgender woman judge you
seem to not be able to hold back your
reaction to the first lady presenting a
biological male from Argentina with an
award for women on International women's
day you know I could be wrong but I
think this is cultural appropriation I
think that they're basically saying that
men
who want to become women are better at
being women than women are they're
erasing they're canceling women and how
sad that the Biden Administration on
International women's day act actually
has to find someone with a male organ to
be a woman and celebrate that person as
a woman and on the same day the U.S came
out saying that trans women can compete
in the power lifting which is an outrage
I mean they they're basically canceling
women and I don't know who else was
honored I hear that Leah Thomas was uh
honored I hear that Rachel Levine was
honored what about real women why why is
it that that they're looking at real
women as not good enough that the men
who want to be women are better than we
are and it it is hurtful it is offensive
uh it erases the dreams of many women
who have worked very hard to get to
certain levels in sports and it is uh it
is crazy town in this country it really
is and I want to say women matter
and that this is this is politics at its
worst Harold what message is this
sending
um the internet exploded over this
moment um with one tweeting out even men
are better at being women than women now
but I think that's one of the points
that the judges make look I'm I'm a
Believer in Freedom and opportunity for
everyone and if you want whomever you
want to be you ought to be able to be
but as a father of of a young daughter
who plays Sports and it's pretty he's
pretty good at sports for her age and I
hope continues to be I'm not settled on
this the whole Sports thing I can't
quite get my arms around how how it's
fair uh to uh and and and to allow this
kind of competition to go back and forth
I don't know the criteria for how the
the the the the awards were given uh but
judge I think the questions that you
raise or questions that that should that
deserve an answer Jesse
think about it I'm not really surprised
that men are better at being women than
women oh
but so I looked into this person Alba
Rueda she's an Argentinian activist for
Trans you know what she did
she did affirmative action for Trans in
Argentina the population of trans in
Argentina is 0.1 percent of the
population wow and she passed a law that
says one percent of all government jobs
have to be trans so trans are now way
over represented the government
Workforce in Argentina and that's the
only reason she got the award
and I'm going to leave it he's
speechless Greg yeah you know you got to
step back and realize like how
artificial this compulsory acceptance
has become it's like where did it come
from it's everywhere and it wasn't like
you know Society got together and said
hey you know what let's help out these
trans people that didn't happen that
that statistic is ridiculous it's absurd
and why it's because it's a combination
of fear of being called transphobic and
also there's got to be money to be made
there has to be you know Harold is
getting at this point which I think we
all agree with which is Live and Let
Live right we all Embrace that right
Wingers Libertarians want to be left
alone this isn't about being equal this
is about you must accept this and say
things that aren't true to you if if you
believe that that is not a real woman
because it's not a biological women and
that it's more than a feeling that all
of a sudden you decide that you're a
woman why can't I decide that I'm black
what if there were what if there was a
movement that just started and all of a
sudden it was like you know at in in
sports or in pageants or wherever
suddenly there was people were
identifying as black we would go like no
why is this different why is this where
did this trickle down from who made this
decision I'm just so curious about how
all of a sudden in five years ago it was
you were born this way now you're in
effect saying that's not true gays are
not biologically gay in fact there's no
such thing as homosexuality because you
know why there's no such thing as
homosexuality because you're fluid and
that means one day you can be gay and
the other day you cannot be gay and
therefore you can take a gay child and
you can surgically change them to like
women or men you can just change their
biology it's insane can I answer your
question yes please there's a lot of
money in these surgeries definitely
that's why yeah it's crazy it's crazy a
lot of money and for the record we would
accept you in the black community why
thank you why thank you I don't think we
would
yeah you're one percent sub-Saharan
Africans
all right we will leave it there hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else